[Musique]
évitez de 5 à 10 ce matin manu l'acquis
clermont désir la future députée du nord
manuela déclare mon désir bonjour vous
êtes par téléphone parce que vous êtes
dans des embouteillages alors vous
n'êtes pas encore au député et pour cela
il faudra attendre samedi l'installation
du conseil municipal de sainte marie
du maire bruno nestor azérot et puis
ensuite sa démission
revenons-en aux déclarations de bruno
des stores à 0 dimanche lors de son
élection il a parlé de charniers en
évoquant ses adversaires politiques vous
partagez cette déclaration où vous vous
désolidariser complètement
je trouve simplement dommage
il a dit énormément de choses dit là il
a parlé de beaucoup du nord beaucoup de
fêtes m'avait beaucoup de des travaux de
ses réalisations était dommage pour
maintiennent que sahin que cet ancien de
son intervention qui fait chaud
l'émotion et surtout la délivrance à
côté parce que la campagne a été
difficile et je les y aillent là il a
reçu beaucoup d' attaque même si le
terme et et forme je fais un portage ou
sexy non non le terme est fort c'est
vrai que c'est à cela qu'on puisse
manquer la voilà il était inappropriée
je pense qu il s'explique aussi là
dessus maintenant on s'arrête pas là
dessus c'est
alors les députés ni lors d'eire a même
publié un communiqué dans lequel ils ne
partagent pas ses déclarations
d'ailleurs en quoi la paix maintenant
l'âme à compter de lundi vous serez donc
la députée du nord vous alliez intérêts
au mip le mouvement initiative populaire
de plus de leicester à 0 si vous pouviez
faire monter vos vitres par contre ce
serait intéressant qu'on n'est pas aussi
le bruit des voitures alors ce que vous
allez adorer au mip locale donc ça veut
dire quoi que vous allez monter votre
propre mouvement sur saint joseph un
mouvement affilié au mip au 1 800 joseph
ou bien côtes allemandes indépendant
avec des citoyens joseph à nous allons
travailler à construire un projet joseph
et qui va s'étaler dans le nord donc
forcément j'ai des liens avec d'accord
concernant le financement des partis
politiques
le financement versé par l'état c'est
votre mouvement alors qui va recevoir
les fonds par le nip
alors aujourd'hui il faut bien
comprendre que c'est une honnête dans
l'aveyron qui a financé la campagne des
législatives
donc il faut être respectueuse
il était avec son mouvement qui là qu'il
a plié et que là qu'il a du président
qui l'a financé toutes les voyez toutes
les campagnes électorales qui se sont
produites ces dernières ces sept
dernières années ont dû donc ces eaux
mais que reviendra en valeur 7
ce financement des partis évidemment mon
mouvement également nous allons partager
d'accord alors parlons de votre fonction
de député il faudra batailler sur la sur
la circonscription pour vous faire
connaître parce que desserte vous avez
participé à la campagne des législatives
de bruno nestor azérot mais c'était lui
le candidat
comment vous comptez vous répondre j'ai
eu avec par le biais de cette fonction a
participé à trois présentations
je souhaitais femmes politiques
jusqu'ici très actif des présentes sur
mon territoire donc être je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de martinique qui me
connaissent maintenant sur le plan va
dire sur la façon de fonctionner mon
travail politique de déficit je tire je
pense je compte rencontrer les maires et
leurs conseils municipal
tout d'abord parce qu'il ya forcément
dans chaque collectivité notamment les
communes un projet à défendre sur le
plan national donc je pense que c'est
d'abord cette démarche à entreprendre et
bien entendu animer des réunions
thématiques sur tout le territoire du
nord avec la population de grand public
est un héros des corps parce que nous
avons une activité on va dire
parlementaires mais il faut qu'à un
moment donné elle ne pas attendre
on va dire la fin de la mandature un nom
après cinq ans après envoyé des
documents et c'est à la population et
qui finalement n'a pas un n'a pas la
porte et qu'on souhaiterait donc je vais
effectivement animés d
et les rencontres avec la population
très bien certains disent que vous
n'êtes pas légitime parce que vous
n'avez pas été élu si bruno les stores à
zéro le camp dit qu'ils étaient
candidats
vous répondez quoi vos détracteurs on
avait bien vous avez utilisé le bon
terme
les détracteurs qui sont pas on va dire
de mon sentiment est qu'ils sont pas
être objectif
mais quand nous allons aux élections
nous avons une année sans rasions et
aller aux élections avec une suppléante
donc je pense qu'il n'a pas choisi sa
superbe par hasard on les sent bien et
c'est bien parce que elle je suis on va
dire active et je représente des valeurs
j'ai ma 10% de popularité qui sait qu'il
m'a choisi donc maintenant je demande
aux gens simplement
arrêtons de juger avant dans ma vie
avant de vraiment connaître et avant que
je sois juste un nouveau travail
alors laissez moi travailler laissez moi
vous vous offrez de quoi je suis capable
et à ce moment là enfin bilan ensuite
enfin lille en est à ce moment là on
pourra juger vous allez ici j'ai ou
soudan le groupe gauche démocrate et
républicaine
dans ce groupe de gounod nestor azérot
d'ailleurs je vais aux rougières de
puilly charbeaux avec avec le groupe je
suis attendu et c'est avec plaisir je
pense que j'avais écrit d'ailleurs quel
que soit le groupe à je pense qu'il est
important avant de de définir groupe
il est important de savoir que je veux
ma liberté de vente et parce qu'il ya
des forcément des textes qui vont être
bien qu'ils ne tenaient sur lesquels je
vais pas forcément être d'accord avec
avec mes collègues et il va falloir que
je puisse moi voter librement et dans
l'intérêt de la martinique
d'accord on a alors on a parlé il nous
reste quelques
seconde on a parlé de saint joseph vous
êtes adjointe au maire de au maire de
saint joseph est normalement 2020 pour
les municipales positive pressentie pour
être candidate à ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité
j'ai été je suis adjointe au maire alors
je fais un travail à côté lunaire
atteint l'âge ingrat
donc voilà on la sait bien tout
politique a le pire à des fonctions
supérieures
donc pour l'instant je ne suis pas cet
entraînement direct alors vous êtes en
train d'arriver justement alors quoi
déplacer il nous reste à peine 20
secondes rapidement voilà vous êtes en
train d'arriver dans nos studios
merci d'avoir fait l'effort d'y de
parvenir jusqu'à nous alors je vous
répète maquette chose que vous êtes et
ce que vous allez être candidate en 2020
alors en 2005 marc je suis plus à l'aise
maintenant pour vous répondre parce que
je marchais de terre la population un
bon nombre de joseph et réclame ma
présence au sein de cette municipalité
ou un niveau supérieur
maintenant je crois que chaque chaque
chose en son temps aujourd'hui je suis
dans une fonction enfin je vais être
amené à assurer une fonction
laissez-moi assumer cette première
fonction est ensuite je reviendrai vers
vous pour vous dire mes projets tous
2020 vous n'avez pas dit non merci manu
la culture et art mondésir bonne journée
à l'écouté de nos programmes bonne
journée à vous tous et merci de m'avoir
invité